Çeviri: Ahmet Erdogan Asliyuce
Gözden geçirme: Batuhan Çevik
Aslında bugün konuşmam
yaşamın bilgisini kullanarak
neler başarabileceğimiz ile ilgili.
Ancak bunu konuşabilmek için
öncesinde bir miktar
yaşamın ne olduğunu tartışmamız gerekiyor.
Bunun için önümüzdeki dakikalarda bütün
hayal gücünüze ihtiyacımız olacak.
Hazırsanız, başlayalım!
Sanırım hiçbirimiz
elimizden kayan bir bardağın
yere düşüp kırılmasını garipsemeyiz.
İçten içe biliriz bu sonucu.
Yerdeki cam parçalarının birleşip
tekrar bardağa dönüştüğünü
veya yerden yükseldiğini göreniniz var mı?
Muhtemelen yoktur.
İyi ama neden?
Bunun sebebi evrenin temelinde
bazı prensipler olması.
Molekülleri, hatta canlıların uzay zamanda
yapacağı davranışları, hareketleri,
yani bir nevi kaderlerini belirleyen
bu prensiplerdir aslında.
Yer çekimi, elektromanyetizma,
bu kavramlara aşinasınızdır.
Bunlar evreni bir arada tutan
en temel kuvvetler.
Bir de bu kuvvetleri bile
açıklamakta kullanılabilen,
pek de o kadar iyi tanımadığımız
bir kuzenleri daha var.
Adı entropi.
Entropi basitçe bir sistemin içerisindeki
düzensizliğin bir ölçütü.
Ama düzensizlik deyip geçmemek lazım,
çünkü düzensizliğin olduğu yerde
olasılıklar, olasılıkların olduğu yerde
ise bilgi var.
Bunu bir örnek üzerinden açıklayalım.
Mesela bir stadyum hayal edin.
Sahadan tribünlere bakıyorsunuz, binlerce
insan aynı anda bir marşı söylüyor.
Herhangi bir anda bir insanın
ağzından çıkan bir kelimeyi
tahmin etmeniz oldukça kolay.
Basit ve organize bir yapı.
Dolayısıyla sistemin bilgisi,
olasılıkları ve entropisi düşük.
Bu yüzden de kırılgan.
Devre arası geldiğinde bütün o düzenin
yerini kaos alıyor.
Siz sahadan baktığınızda tribünlere
karman çorman anlamsız bir kalabalık
görüyorsunuz ama, eğer tribünlerin
arasında yürüyecek olursanız,
insanların birbirleriyle etkileşime
geçtiklerini, binlerce farklı konudan
konuştuklarını, belki milyonlarca farklı
hareket yaptığını göreceksiniz.
Termodinamiğin ikinci kanunu,
yani entropi kanunu,
bize bunun neden böyle olduğunu açıklar.
Hala tam olarak bilmediğimiz
bir sebepten ötürü
evren bütün düzeni bozarak
kaosa sürüklemeye meyillidir her şeyi.
Eğer bir çocuğunuz varsa bu prensibi
benden çok daha iyi anladığınıza eminim.
Siz zorlamadığınız sürece
asla düzenlenmeyen
ve sonsuza kadar daha da
dağınık olmayı başarabilen odalar
muhtemelen size yabancı gelmiyordur.
Ofisteki masam buna oldukça iyi bir örnek.
Biz insanlar evrenin temelindeki
prensipleri kullanmayı öğrenerek bugün
motorları, bilgisayarları, yapay zekayı,
hatta robotları geliştirdik.
Şimdi ise bunların birleşip akıllanacağını
ve bizi, insanoğlunu ele geçirecekleri
günlerden bahsediyoruz.
Bu senaryo bana bir yerden
tanıdık geliyor.
Çünkü bildiğimiz kadarıyla
bundan en az 3.8 milyar yıl önce
çok zeki bir robot ırkı gezegenimizi
çoktan ele geçirdi.
Böyle söyleyince
kulağa garip geldiğini biliyorum.
Ama aslında bize o kadar da yabancı değil
bu hücreler... Bu robotlar.
Günümüzde onlara hücre diyoruz.
Evren, yeterince enerji ve zaman,
uygun koşulların da varlığında,
yaşam adını verdiğimiz
kendi kendini inşa edebilen,
çevresini manipüle edebilen,
hesap yapıp karar verebilen
kimyasal çorbanın bilgisini
mikroskobik yağ damlacıklarının
içerisine hapsetmeyi başardı
ve hücreleri meydana getirdi.
Gelin isterseniz biraz daha yakından
tanıyalım bu yaratıkları.
Mesela bir bakteriyi ele alalım.
Bu yaratıklar o kadar küçük ki
bir tanesi bir insan boyutunda olsaydı
insanlar Pasifik okyanusu
kadar büyük olurdu.
İçlerine girdiğimizde üç temel molekülden
oluşan bir sistemle karşılaşıyoruz.
DNA, RNA ve protein.
Yaşamın sürdürülebilmesi ve
tekrar oluşturulabilmesi için
gerekli bütün talimatlar
DNA’nın şifresi üzerinde kodlu.
RNA’larsa DNA’lardan aldığı
bu talimatları hücre içerisinde taşıyan
ve sistemi düzenleyen moleküller.
Proteinler sistemin işlevsel makinaları.
Enerji harcayarak kendilerine atanan
görevleri yerine getiriyorlar.
Ve bir hücrenin içerisinde
bu moleküllerden milyonlarca var,
sürekli etkileşiyorlar.
Bunu karışık bir yemek tabağına
benzetebilirsiniz.
Ve bütün mevzu aslında
birtakım patateslerin bir araya gelip
biberlerden aldığı kırmızı renkleri
kıymaların üzerine vermesiyle alakalı.
İyi de bu patatesler ne yapacağını
nereden biliyor?
İşte tam burada entropi
tekrar devreye giriyor.
Aynı evrenin kendisi gibi
bütün moleküler sistemler de
sürekli olarak entropilerini
arttırmaya çalışır.
Bu onlara bir çeşit davranış kazandırır.
Ve bu davranışlardan milyonlarcası bir
hücre içerisinde bir araya geldiğinde
garip bir şekilde bu yaratıklara
birbirlerini kovalayabilecek
zekayı kazandırırlar.
İyi haber bu yaratıklardan
korkmamıza gerek yok.
Çünkü sütü ilk mayaladığımız,
ilk toprağa tohumu ektiğimiz günden
bu günlere bu yaratıklarla ilgili
ciddi miktarda bilgi elde ettik.
Öyle ki artık genetik sistemlerine girip
onları istediğimiz özellikleri kazanmaya
veya istediğimiz işleri yapmaya
programlayabiliyoruz.
Mesela kullandığınız insülin, bazı kanser
ilaçları, farnesene adında bir biyoyakıt,
hatta marketten satın aldığınız vanilin
bugün programlanmış hücrelerle üretiliyor.
Bu enteresan alanda
üniversiteye başladığım ilk yıllarda
bir şeyler öğrenebilmek için
kongre kongre geziniyordum.
Çok iyi hatırlıyorum bir keresinde
Hacettepe Üniversitesi'nde
bir nanotıp kongresi vardı.
Tesadüfen de organizasyon komitesindeki
akademisyenlerden bir tanesi
benim annemin bir arkadaşıydı.
Ben de İstanbul'dan
büyük bir heyecanla kalktım,
Ankara'ya gittim, konuşmaları dinledim,
her dinlediğim konuşmada
biraz daha heyecanlandım.
Sonra iki konuşma arasında çıkıp
annemin arkadaşını Mehmet Abi'yi yakaladım
ve daha tanışmaya bile adam gibi
fırsat vermeden aldığım o gazla
başladım fikir kusmaya.
Sağolsun Mehmet Abi de
sabırla beni dinledi.
Söyleyecek başka sözüm kalmadığında da
dönüp bana dedi ki:
"Oğlum ben de senin gibi aynı,
üniversiteye ilk başladığım yıllarda
çok büyük hayallerle geldim buraya.
"Mesela benim hayalim kanatlı insanlar yapmaktı.
"Gel gör ki işin içine girdikten sonra
biyolojik bilimlerde
kullandığımız metotların
hala çok ilkel olduğunu fark ettim.
"Kanatlı insanlar yapmak nerede,
küçük küreciklerin içerisine
ilaç molekülleri sıkıştırmaya
çalışmak nerede..."
İki dakika içinde Mehmet Abi
bütün dünyamı başıma yıkmıştı.
İşin kötü tarafı
adam oldukça haklıydı.
Güneş Sistemi'nin en ücra köşelerindeki
kuyruklu yıldızların üzerine
uydu indirmeyi başarabilen insanoğlu,
biyolojik bilimler söz konusu olduğunda
oldukça ilkel yöntemlere muhtaçtı.
Daha sonra bunun neyden kaynaklandığını
anlamam çok zor olmadı.
Bütün genetik yapılar talimat
ve genetik dil sistemi ile çalışıyor.
Genetik dil sürekli talimatları okurken
talimatlar da genetik dili oluşturan
mekanizmayı inşa ediyor.
Bunun en güzel örneği de sizsiniz aslında.
Annenizden bir miktar talimat,
babanızdan bir miktar talimat
bu hayata başladığınız ilk gün
tek bir hücrenin içerisinde
bir araya geliyor.
Ve o hücrenin içerisindeki genetik dil
bu talimatlarda ne yazıyorsa
sırayla onları okuyarak o tek hücreden
bugün bütün özelliklerinizle
sizi meydana getiriyor.
Mesela anne karnındayken önce başınız
büyüyor, vücudunuz genişliyor,
omuzlarınızdan çıkıntılar ayrılıyor.
Bu çıkıntıların sonuna doğru
belirli aralıklarla hücreler ölmeye
kalanlarsa kemikleşmeye başlıyor.
N'oluyor?
Bugünkü elleriniz meydana geliyor.
Problem daha buralardan başlıyor.
Bir kere her organizmanın
kendi genetik talimatları
ve onları okuyan kendi
genetik dili var.
Yani evrensel bir şey yok ortada.
Uzun yıllar boyunca insanlar nasıl
antik dilleri çözmek için
yazıtları okuduysa
genetik mühendisleri de
doğadan topladıkları hücrelerin
talimatlarını okuyarak
onların genetik dillerini çözmeye çalıştı.
Aslında bu konuda
oldukça da başarılı olduk.
Çözebildiğimiz kadarıyla genetik dillerin
içerisinde işimize yarayacak parçaları
bugün parça kütüphaneleri dediğimiz
şeylerin altında topladık.
Ve bir hücreye bir şey yaptırmak
istediğimizde şimdi gidiyoruz,
o parça kütüphanelerinden
ihtiyacımız olan parçaları alıp
bir DNA molekülü üzerinde
birleştirerek hücrelere aktarıyoruz.
Ne yazık ki 3.8 milyar yıllık arge,
hücrelere oldukça karmaşık
bir genetik dil kazandırmış.
Bizimse bu karmaşayı hesaplayabilecek
ne yeterince kuvvetli bilgisayarlarımız,
ne de bu karmaşayla başa çıkabilecek
araç gerecimiz mevcut.
Bu yüzden hücrelerin içerisine kurduğumuz
sistemler uzun süre dayanmıyor.
Süreçlerimiz hesaplanabilir olmadığı için
oldukça deneysel ve çalışan bir prototip
elde etmek bazen binlerce defa
tekrar denemeyi gerektiriyor.
Üstelik kullandığımız ilkel yöntemler
o kadar çok enerji kaybına
sebep oluyor ki,
hücrelerin...
İstediğimiz verimde üretim yapan hücreler
elde etmek neredeyse mümkün değil.
Uzun yıllar boyunca ortam ağırlığı ölçen
ve bütün Geen Bio Teknoloji ekibi ile
yapay örümcek ipeğinden ilaç moleküllerine
birçok endüstriyel ürün üreten
hücre hattı geliştiriyoruz.
Ve her seferinde genetik dilin
karmaşıklığı ve sürecin deneyselliğiyle
tekrar tekrar yüzleşmek zorunda kalıyoruz.
Ve artık eminiz ki
genetik mühendisliğinin
bir sonraki adıma geçebilmesi için
bu problemin kesinlikle
çözülmesi gerekiyor.
Elbette bu problemin çözülmesi gerektiğini
düşünen tek ekip biz değiliz.
Geçtiğimiz yıl Amerika'da
Craig Venter Enstitüsü
aldıkları bir hücrenin içerisindeki
bütün gereksiz genleri atarak
şu an yaşayan en basit hücresel
organizmayı geliştirmeyi başardılar.
Ama bunu yaparken bu hücrelere
o kadar zarar verdiler ki
hücreler endüstriyel
yeteneklerini de kaybetti.
Başka bir ekip benzer bir yöntemle
başka organizmalarda çalıştı
onlar da basitleştirmekte
yeterince başarılı olamadı.
Bizlerse farklı bir yöntem izledik,
çünkü basit bir genetik dil
oluşturmak konusunda
bizden daha eski ve deneyimli
birilerinin olduğunun farkındaydık:
Virüsler
Virüslere, hücrelere istediklerini
yaptırmak konusunda,
istediklerini yaptırmak için basit ve
kompak çözümler üretmek konusunda
dahidirler desek yeridir.
Bizler de bu yaşam formlarından
ilham alarak bundan yaklaşık iki yıl önce
GeenOS adını verdiğimiz,
bir hücrenin içerisine aktarıldığı anda
hücrenin içerisinde evrensel, basit ve
hesaplanılabilir ikinci bir genetik dili
ortaya çıkaracak bir DNA molekülü
geliştirmeye başladık.
Şimdi size muhtemelen
bugüne kadar yapılmış
en karmaşık genetik mühendisliği
çalışmalarından bir tanesini
olabildiğince basit bir şekilde
anlatmaya çalışacağım.
Bir kere bir genetik dil elde etmek için
önce DNA’dan RNA üreten
mekanizmaya ihtiyacınız var.
Bizler bunu bir virüs ailesinden
alarak sistemin kalbi haline getirdik.
Sonrasında hücreler büyüdükçe
sizin DNA’nızın da artabilmesi için
DNA'dan yeni DNA’lar üretecek bir sistemi
başka bir virüs ailesinden alıp
geliştirerek sisteme ekledik.
Uzun çalışmalar sonucunda RNA’lardan
protein üretecek bir mekanizmayı da
bakterilerden toparladıktan sonra
geriye bir tek sistemi düzenlemek kaldı.
Bunu da programlanabilir
proteinler kullanarak yaptık.
Son olarak bu genetik dilin iskeletini
oluşturmuş olduk ve son olarak
genetik mühendislerinin bu genetik dille
etkileşime geçebilmesi, komutları
ve talimatları verebilmeleri için
son bir modülü de sisteme ekledikten sonra
GeenOS'in ilk prototipini
tamamlamış olduk.
Sistemin amacı aslında
genetik mühendisliği süreçlerine
basit bir genetik dil sağlayarak
süreçlerin hesaplanabilirliğini arttırıp
deneyselliğini azaltmaktı.
Ama bu sistemi geliştirirken
enteresan bir şeyle karşılaştık.
Sistemin DNA’sı simülasyonlara
koyduğumuzda giderek çoğalıyordu
ve bir süre sonra hücrelerin
büyümesini engelliyordu.
Bunun için literatürde bir araştırma
yaptık ve bu sistemle karşılaştık.
Burada gördüğünüz her bir nokta
bir proteini temsil ediyor
ve her bir proteinin artması diğer iki
proteinin artışını baskılıyor.
Makale şunu öneriyordu:
Eğer doğru parametreler sağlanırsa
böyle bir sistem, üzerinde bulunduğu
DNA'nın sayısını sayabilir,
saydığı sayıyı hatırlayabilir,
hatta bu artışa tepki verebilirdi.
Tam olarak ihtiyacımız olan sistem.
Ama çok ciddi bir problem vardı.
Bu sistem tamamen bilgisayarda
geliştirilmiş sanal bir sistemdi,
yani gerçekte bir karşılığı yoktu.
Parça kütüphanelerimizdeki parçalarla
böyle bir sistemi inşa etmek
olası değildi.
Tam depresyona girecektik ki aklımıza
çok önemli bir şey geldi.
Şu ana kadar geliştirdiğimiz sistemin
içerisindeki programlanabilir proteinler
hesaplanabilir bir genetik dille
bir araya geldiğinde
daha önce hiç farkına varmadığımız
bir şeyi mümkün kılıyordu.
Bazı DNA parçalarını istediğimiz
özelliklere gelecek şekilde
bilgisayarda hesaplayabilir
hale geliyorduk.
Bu ne demek?
Tamamen bilgisayarda hesaplanmış ve sanal
bir genetik sistemi hücreler içerisinde
çalışır hale getirilebilmesi demek.
GeenOS'in kendi gelişimini
kolaylaştırışına tanık olmak
bizi bu sistemin genetik mühendisliğinde
yeni ufuklar açacağı konusunda
ikinci kez ikna etti.
Geleneksel genetik mühendisliği
süreçlerinde biz genelde
dört aşamadan oluşan bir döngü izliyoruz.
Önce bilgisayarda bir sistem tasarlıyoruz.
Daha sonra bunu DNA olarak inşa ediyoruz.
Hücrelerin içlerine aktarıyoruz ve deney
sonuçlarını elde edip o sonuçlardan
bir şeyler öğrenerek genetik tasarım
tahtasının başına geçiyoruz.
Ama normalde yaptığımız hesaplamaların
doğrulukları oldukça düşük olduğu için
zamanımızın ve paramızın çok büyük kısmını
inşa ve deney aşamalarından
tekrar tekrar geçerek
harcamak zorunda kalıyoruz.
Halbuki GeenOS gibi bir platformla,
tasarım aşamasında çok daha yüksek
doğrulukla hesaplamalar yaparak inşa ve
deney aşamasında harcadığımız zaman
ve parayı on kata kadar azaltmamız mümkün.
Tamam, güzel.
Programlanabilir hücreler geliştirmek için
elimizde bir platform var.
"İyi de programlanabilir hücreler
benim hayatımda ne işe yarayacak?"
derseniz size birkaç örnek vermek isterim.
Mesela şu an derinizde bir enfeksiyon
olduğunda, diyelim ki mantar enfeksiyonu,
n'apıyorsunuz, doktora gidip
bir ilaç yazdırıyorsunuz
ve o mikropları öldürmek için sürekli
o ilacı uyguluyorsunuz.
Halbuki programlanabilir hücreler
sizinle bağırsaklarınızda veya derinizde
ömür boyu yaşayarak sizin bu hastalıklara,
hatta bazen viral hastalıklara,
hiç yakalanmamanızı sağlamak için
sizi ömür boyu koruyabilirler.
Yaşamınızı uzatabilirler.
Mesela bir şeker hastası
reaktörlerde yine programlanmış hücreler
tarafından üretilen insülini dışarıdan
ilaç olarak düzenli olarak almak zorunda.
Halbuki bu reaktörlerdeki bakterileri
biraz daha iyi programlayabilirsek
bu hastaların ömür boyunca
ihtiyaçları olan insülini
ihtiyaçları kadar doğru zamanda
sağlamamız mümkün olabilir.
Başka bir örnek: kıkırdak aşınması.
Bu rahatsızlıkta şu an
elimizdeki en iyi yöntem
kök hücreleri laboratuvarda büyütüp
bir miktar rical niteliğindeki kimyasalla
karıştırarak eklemlere enjekte etmek
ve hücrelerin kendi kendine
ne yapacağını bulmasını ummak.
Halbuki bu hücrelere
eğer söz geçirebilsek,
onlara yapmaları gereken şeyi
doğrudan gösterebiliriz.
İlla medikal alanda olmak
zorunda da değil.
Endüstrimiz de oldukça
dengesiz bir konumda.
Sürekli olarak doğal kaynakları harap edip
endüstriyel atıklar ortaya çıkarıyoruz.
Halbuki bu zincirin kayıp halkası
sentetik biyoloji.
Programlanabilir hücreler
endüstriyel atıkları
tekrar doğal kaynaklara dönüştürmekte
veya tekrar kullandığımız
ürünlere dönüştürmekte
oldukça verimli bir platform.
Gördüğünüz gibi yapabileceğimiz
birçok şey var.
Ve biz insanlar için yaşam
artık bir tabu değil.
Bir mühendislik alanı.
Kim bilir Antik Yunanlardan beri süregelen
Hazerfen’in de, Hacettepe'deki
Mehmet Abi'nin de hayalini paylaştığı
kanatlı insanlar belki bize sandığımız
kadar uzak değildir.
Teşekkürler!